[Applauso]
Avete presente i sommelier
colore intenso Guarda che antociani al
naso nessuna riduzione anzi sentori
cristallini di mela mela annurca nomi la
cotogna stufata in un Paiolo di rame con
chiodi di garofano e cannella
cannella indiana
nessun segno di malolattica Anzi
arrivano i terziari di cuoio usato non
ho questo e Cuoio sudato della sella del
cavallo di John Wayne al galoppo
siete d'accordo no come no Come
contraddire una sommelier Soprattutto
dopo una supercazzola del genere
Missione impossibile certi
Professionisti del vino hanno proprio
questo superpotere di farci sentire
inadeguati Immagina la scena magari ti è
capitato sei al ristorante con gli amici
o se ti è andata peggio coi parenti
succede per una congiuntura astrale di
sfighe che dopo 10 minuti di rimpallo
della carta dei vini Manco fosse un
tizzone ardente o una cambiale sei
proprio tu
sei tu Il prescelto colui che deve
prendersi la responsabilità di scegliere
il vino
se sei capitato in un posto Gourmet o
stellato
ti sarà stata depositata davanti una
carta dei vini formato elenco del
telefono se ti va bene È divisa per aree
geografiche o denominazioni inizia a
sfogliarla guardare non ci capisci
niente cru Premiere crudo riserva gran
riserva millesimato brute Extra Dry un
casino arrivi alla sezione vini dal
mondo e ancora peggio ma dice almeno ci
sono i numeri che sono le annate o i
prezzi
ti sorge il dubbio e comincia andare nel
panico allora decidi di applicare le
uniche due regole che conosci rosso con
la carne bianco con il pesce Quindi
guardi i tuoi commensali e cerchi
rassicurazioni cerchi di capire cosa
mangiano e loro per facilitarti il
compito hanno ovviamente ordinato a caso
c'è chi ha preso le ostriche e chi lo
stinco con la polenta ecco
inizia a sudare freddo comincia avere
delle allucinazioni del tuo esame di
maturità e in lontananza vedi che arriva
lui il sommelier con il sogghigno sadico
pronto a sfoderare la sua domanda
retorica preferita
signore ha visto qualcosa di
interessante
Cala il silenzio
i tuoi commensali con le braccia
conserte si godono lo spettacolo tu sei
lì su di freddo
tic tic tic il cronometro scorre e
deglutisci hai la gola secca non hai
ancora bevuto niente Insomma e inizia a
farfugliare ma iniziamo con un bianco un
rosso un Rosato un frizzante non si dice
spumante uno chardo uno shampoo un
prosecchino No no
frosecchino non si dice e finalmente
dopo un interminabile minuto di vergogna
alzi gli occhi e dici L'unica cosa
sensata
faccio a lei
[Musica]
Come mai è così difficile scegliere il
vino e come mai questo non succede con
Altre bevande alcoliche prendiamo la
birra immagino a quest'altra scena
stavolta sei al pub con gli amici magari
anche uno di quelle È una di quelle
birrerie un po' infiocchettate che ha la
carta delle birre artigianali che
ovviamente non sarà mai l'elenco del
telefono la leggi non ti intimorisce
Anzi pure divertente vedere i nomi
ironici irriverenti che certi birrifici
artigianali scelgono per i loro prodotti
per le loro birre come un'estate amara o
bestemmia on the beach o la mia
preferita il luppolo perde il pelo lo
Quindi in realtà ti fai una risata e
ordinare non ti intimorisce non hai
paura di sbagliare a prendere quella o
quella tra shedi la birra che più ti
incuriosisce la ordini il cameriere te
la porta e te la godi
te la godi semplice semplice non c'è
complicazione e invece il vino che ormai
io lo conosco lo studio da più di dieci
anni e lo comunico è quella bevanda Anzi
Oserei dire quel prodotto alimentare che
ha calato il maggior numero di
pregiudizi volete gli esempi un bel
Rosato per la signora o ancora Questo
vino è dolce piace alle donne nel mio
settore persino i colori e i sapori
hanno un genere D'altra parte quando vai
al ristorante La carta dei vini viene
sempre data all'uomo al tavolo e poi
quando il vino lo scelgo io ovvero
sempre in realtà viene poi portato a lui
per capire se va bene e se può essere
servito
ma non è tutto Prendiamo il lessico i
vocaboli se io vi dico prendiamo una
birretta con gli amici o ci facciamo un
grappino in compagnia di strappo un
sorriso No bello ma se vi offro un
vinello
non so se lo accettereste vinello è
considerato dozzinale o da femminucce
Aridaje quindi viene usato per cucinare
o viene dato alle donne Oppure viene
dato alle donne per cucinare così
chiudiamo il cerchio dello stereotipo
tutto a posto
[Musica]
ma andiamo avanti persino i vitigni
Ovvero le uve utilizzate per produrre
vino o le denominazioni cioè i luoghi
dove il vino viene prodotto sono oggetto
di pregiudizio se bevi Lambrusco Beh se
è ossidato
se bevi burgogni o bordeaux o qualsiasi
cosa sia francese Beh sei un figo
pazzesco Beh Allora potremmo provare per
esempio a pronunciare in francese i
nostri vini un bel lambroscò prosecco un
Barbera decisamente Fatemi poi sapere se
funziona E sì quindi il vino e la
leggerezza non vanno di pari passo E
come mai questo succede perché per tanti
anni Il vino è stato comunicato in modo
asettico sicuramente il sommelier o i
degustatori professionisti con il loro
linguaggio un po' ostico non hanno
avvicinato le persone comuni al vino e
questo però se ci pensate capita anche
per altri ambiti non so prendiamo L'arte
o la cultura sono passatempi ha torto
considerati aristocratici come se per
goderne fosse necessario far parte di un
Elite
e ma nemmeno gli esperti possono tanto
prenderla alla leggera è capitato anche
a me sapete tre anni fa un noto
giornalista di settore mi ha
letteralmente bullizzata all Nine perché
ho osato dire che un Riesling
invecchiato un Riesling è uno dei più
famosi vini bianchi tedeschi o alsaziani
insomma questo risvegli invecchiato mi
ricordava quell'odore della palestra
delle scuole medie Avete presente quella
zaffata dell'ora di educazione fisica Ok
non era un difetto eh sono gli
idrocarburi insomma io ho Esatto evocare
questo ricordo e
sacrilegio
sacrilegio sono stata dipinta come il
pagliaccio della degustazione e lui sul
suo blog si è scatenato per giorni con
articoli in cui commentava il mio
aspetto fisico che voglio dire cosa
c'entra e anche la presunta frequenza
delle mie attività sessuali
un signore un signore
Quindi anche noi esperti non possiamo
utilizzare un linguaggio comune semplice
leggero Eppure di riportare la
leggerezza nella comunicazione del vino
Io ne ho fatta veramente una missione
racconto il vino italiano agli americani
cerco di farli innamorare ancora di più
del vino italiano raccontando tutto
quello che sta intorno al bicchiere gli
uomini le donne che coltivano le Vigne
Cerco di portare con la mente le persone
nei luoghi del vino che sapete Sono
meravigliosi perché il vino buono si fa
nei posti belli e io aggiungo lo fanno
le persone felici Mario Soldati è un
famoso scrittore lo conoscete tutti
forse non sapete che era anche un noto
giornalista del vino e lui diceva che
per conoscere il vino devi consumare la
suola delle scarpe
magari non queste Il senso era per
conoscere il vino devi viverlo
ed è così se ci pensi quei profumi e
quei sentori quei Sapori che raccontiamo
durante le degustazioni se ovviamente
fatto con sincerità non la supercazzola
di prima altro non sono questi profumi
che ricordi esperienze
e non ci sono ricordi Giusti e ricordi
sbagliati no i ricordi sono miei Sono
tuoi sono nostri nessuno li può
giudicare nessuno
[Musica]
per esempio un vino a me può ricordare
Non so le rose secche che la mia nonna
metteva nel cassetto della biancheria
per profumarla a un giapponese lo stesso
profumo un po' Acre dolce può ricordare
i fiori di ibisco che asciugano il sole
dopo un temporale come faccio io a dire
al giapponese No ma chi ibisco Ti sbagli
sono le rose secche del cassetto di mia
nonna è sbagliato completamente quello
neanche le ha mai annusate le rose
secche come io non ho mai annusato
l'ibisco che asciuga il sole quindi non
c'è giusto sbagliato la chiave quindi è
tornare a godere del vino con leggerezza
congenuità con semplicità senza aver
paura del giudizio perché finisce che
per paura di ordinare questa o
quell'altra bottiglia Beviamo sempre le
stesse cose scelte dagli altri e questo
succede anche per gli altri ambiti per
l'arte per la cultura se noi riusciamo
non vergognarci della nostra ignoranza
ma a farne Il trampolino per le nuove
scoperte per la nostra curiosità
riusciremo a godere dei piaceri della
vita in modo semplice e leggero ci
libereremo dal peso della vergogna
Quindi la prossima volta che un
sommelier è una sommelier ti depositerà
davanti la carta dei vini formato elenco
del telefono non aspettare che venga lui
o lei a interrogarti sentendoti anche un
po' inadeguato sei tu con fierezza ad
accogliere la tua ignoranza e a chiedere
Raccontami la storia più bella che c'è
in questa carta dei vini se mi
affascinerà ordinerò quella bottiglia
anche se la più cara magari e me la
godrò fino all'ultima goccia perché non
deve più succedere che la tua voglia di
curiosità e di scoperta resti sepolta
sotto quelle due paroline dette con
l'ascella pezzata faccia a lei mai più
mai più
In altri casi
Grazie
[Applauso]